right now Arizona's the border patrol
suspending operations at the border
crossing into the Tucson sector why they
have to free up agents dealing with
soaring migrants CBP sources tell Fox
News nearly 5,000 illegal immigrants
tried Crossing there in just one 24-hour
period over the weekend part of the
10,000 who cross the Southwest border
our next guest says Biden's border
policies are to blame Arizona GOP Senate
candidate Carrie Lake joins us now uh
Carrie great to see you you've seen this
board you've been there a lot what makes
it different now that so many people
seem
panicked you know I don't know if it's
that that uh Greg Abbott is getting more
tough on the border and they've decided
to funnel everybody through Arizona but
Arizona is being hit the hardest right
now the Tucson sector is completely out
of control I talked to a businessman
last night who is very much involved in
the border and he wants to make sure
that the legal ports of Entry are open
because his business relies on that
they're shutting down legal ports of
Entry where business is conducted where
tourists go back and forth where uh you
know agriculture trucks come back and
forth they're shutting those down to
take the resources and put them out to
process people pouring across illegally
can you even imagine that they they shut
they're shutting down the lukeville Port
of Entry you're looking at it right now
because they don't have the staff to
handle the legal business coming in and
out because they're dealing with the
illegals that are coming in and out and
it's at a crisis point right now the uh
the video that shocked me the most was a
couple days ago a reporter was down
there and I think your reporter bill has
been down there to spot like this as
well and a bunch of cartel members were
literally moved in the heavy equipment
to chop down parts of the wall so that
they could have people just flow in
through the wall right and they were
laughing as the reporter was videotaping
them and blowing kisses at the reporter
I mean they're mocking us they are
literally
and your
govern and your Governor doesn't care so
you you want to be the next senator from
Arizona obviously if the Republic is
going to take the Senate a seat like uh
like yours has to be one would you be
better off in a three-person race with
gyo and Senator Cinema who left the
Democratic party to become an
independent or are you better off in a
one-on-one
situation you know there's arguments to
be made for both I mean Kirsten Cinema
is not a moderate she's trying to act
like she is but since she became an
independent last year she's voted 100%
of the time with Joe Biden's agenda 100%
of the time so she's trying to fool the
people of Arizona but the people of
Arizona are so fed up with Joe Biden's
out ofc control economy out ofc control
border out of control uh you know
violence around the globe that they're
ready for a change so it really doesn't
matter I think you could make an
argument that she's going to take some
votes from the Republicans and the
Democrats but I saw her internal memo
which showed that she would need to get
600,000 Trump voters in order to win I
just don't think there's a lot of trump
cinem of Voters out there especially
with me on the ballot right uh so best
of luck it's going to be a tight race
and uh the whole party depends on it so
not much pressure on your shoulders Cary
Lake good luck I'm working hard I'm
working hard you can go to carry
lake.com to help out we got to win this
seat all right uh good luck I'll talk to
you again soon I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis